[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
depuis toujours j'ai été indigné par
toutes les inégalités toutes les
injustices
je suis donc devenu très très rapidement
féministe et puis depuis 20 ans je suis
une chaîne de garde ça j'ai eu peur vous
n'êtes pas les seuls que de fantasmes
autour de ce monde et que de fantasmes
autour aussi du mot féminisme mais
pourtant je suis juste sur mes gardes je
ne bois pas je ne mords pas je suis
vigilante 1 et ma mission de féministes
c'est de lutter contre les violences
symboliques qui sont faites aux femmes
quotidiennement dans l'espace public
notamment dans le langage et dans les
images mais c'est pas facile à porter et
c'est pas non plus facile pour mon
entourage
quand je suis en réunion familiale
amicale militante et qu'on me demande
auprès de qui je suis engagé et que je
réponds je suis la présidente des
chiennes de garde
instantanément tous les regards se
tournent vers mon compagnon
plein de commisération d'étonnement quel
homme
et oui c'est facile mais justement ces
fantasmes ne sont que des fantasmes
d'ailleurs dans mon militantisme comme
je suis beaucoup appelé à travailler
avec des gens de la publicité j'ai
appris que une personne très importante
dans ce secteur
trouvez que on pouvait pas discuter avec
moi parce que chiennes de garde non
c'est radical
ça fait la guerre aux hommes non non
c'est pas possible je l'appelle je lui
demande un rendez vous
et puis au bout d'une demi heure elle me
dit quand même drôlement content que
vous ayez forcé ma porte parce que vous
n'êtes pas du tout celle que je croyais
bah oui quand même la pédagogie et puis
vous souriez vous êtes pas agressive
avance comme ça que vous voyez les
féministes et oui oui que de fantasmes
et pourtant pourtant ce mode de chiennes
de garde
il est juste venu d'une discussion entre
copines bien vingt ans on voulait
s'engager contre ces violences
symboliques faites aux femmes dans
l'espace public langage images on a
tourné brainstorming lit très vite est
venue la vigilance la vigilance des
chiens de garde
mais bien sûr on était quand même une
majorité de femmes dont très vite ce
sont les chiennes de garde qui sont
arrivés et puis en 10 anciennes de garde
on se disait ah quand même
c'est plutôt rigolo parce que là plein
de gens qui vont nous poser des
questions qui vont être horrifié on va
pouvoir faire de la pédagogie et voilà
c'est en partie pour ça que je suis là
devant vous ce soir c'est décalé
effectivement mais pourquoi tous ses
fantasmes
pourquoi ces stéréotypes 1 sur les
féministes et notamment sur les chaînes
de garde
pourtant ce n'est due que
aux stéréotypes que la vie quotidienne
nous impose ça a été prouvé par par la
grande anthropologue françoise héritier
il ya parlé de la valence différentielle
des sexes essais de valence
différentielle des sexes elle est
devenue une une cascade de stéréotypes
on croit que selon qu'on est mené une
femme ou un homme
une fille ou un garçon on à telle ou
telle attitude dans la vie par exemple
manifestement nous les femmes on aurait
un syndrome du shopping on aurait le
gène de la carte bleue et les hommes eux
il aurait le syndrome de la grosse
voiture ou des muscles et bien non tout
ça les neurobiologistes s'y penche
beaucoup dernièrement ça n'est pas vrai
ce sont des fantasmes ce sont des idées
reçues
et pourtant et pourtant même la loi s'y
est mise pendant les 35 dernières années
il ya eu 28 loi et 400 textes qui ont
été éditées pour essayer d'amener à
l'égalité et pourtant
j'imagine que vous le savez toutes et
tous ici les femmes gagnent aujourd'hui
25% de moins que les hommes tous métiers
confondus 9% de moins à messiers égal
les femmes retraités touchent une
retraite de 42% moindre que celle des
hommes
aujourd'hui un tiers des femmes qui
travaillent sont obligés de travailler à
temps partiel s'appelle du temps partiel
subi et seulement 7% des hommes
et puis il y a toujours une femme sur
dix
il subit des violences conjugales
malheureusement une femme tous les trois
jours qui meurt sous les coups de son
conjoint ou très souvent de son ex
conjoint qui lui refuse la liberté et
puis depuis que je vous parle il y a eu
au moins deux viols et quand j'aurai
fini au moins un troisième en france et
on dit que les féministes veulent la
guerre des sexes
je rappellerai le beau mot de benoît
drujon qui dit le féminisme n'a jamais
tué personne mais le machisme tue tous
les jours
pourquoi cette violence pourquoi ces
stéréotypes
pourquoi ces rôles attribués aux femmes
d'un côté aux hommes de l'autre pourquoi
ces injonctions à rentrer dans des
schémas qui ne sont que des schémas
inventé au départ donc je rappelais la
valence différentielle des sexes pour
une histoire de contrôle de la
reproduction est en fait de ceux de cet
énorme chose qui est finalement là la
reproduction humaine a découlé toutes
ces idées reçues qui nous pourrissent la
vie et qui empêche l'égalité
j'ai fait un petit test qui pensant que
les hommes aujourd'hui font plus de
travail à la maison qui lie à 25 ans
bah oui pas mal vous savez les hommes
font aujourd'hui depuis 25 ans six
minutes de plus de travail à la maison
avant les femmes continue quand même à
faire 80 % des tâches domestiques plus
la charge mentale
je ne parle pas de veine petit test est
ce que vous pensez que les filles
choisissent plus des filières
scientifiques dans les lycées non 40 %
des filles choisissent les filières
scientifiques au lycée et 27% les
filières littéraires
donc vous voyez nous avons tous des
idées reçues qu'il nous faut combattre
et c'est pour ça aussi que je suis là ce
soir parce que c'est pas vrai que les
hommes viennent de mars et les femmes de
vénus
même si c'est assez rigolo de le dire
est que ç'a eu beaucoup de succès
l'injonction à ce que les sommes soient
forts virils ne pleure jamais et des
grosses voitures gagnent beaucoup
d'argent et l'injonction que les femmes
soient souriante jolies qu'elles
s'occupent de leurs enfants et des
personnes âgées
bref le caire comme on dit et ben non
tout ça ça n'est pas l'égalité est donc
ce soir c'est ce que je vous propose
c'est d'agir tous ensemble pour
l'égalité moi je milite parce que je
pense que le monde sera meilleur
entre les femmes et les hommes dans
l'égalité arrivera je pense aussi que
l'égalité c'est un marqueur démocratique
je pense aussi que militer ça permet de
réussir quelque chose que quelque chose
soit au bout du chemin
parce que en fait c'est le chemin qui
est important et c'est la pédagogie qui
est importante
aujourd'hui on a réussi quand même pas
mal de
11 à force d'aller voir des
publicitaires il y en a plein qui ont
pris là qui ont promis qu' il ferait
très attention ils liraient leurs
publicités et leurs slogans leurs images
et le langage à l'aune de la du
féminisme
vous voyez qu'il ya du travail quand
même encore et puis je milite aussi
parce que finalement comme tout un
chacun
le plus beau cadeau qu'on puisse faire à
un homme ou une femme qui est à ses
côtés
c'est de vivre sa vie en tant que femme
libre ça c'est doris lessing qui le dit
mais je crois que tous les jours on peut
on peut le vivre
et puis enfin je milite parce que c'est
une des bonnes façons d'être optimiste
parce que finalement c'est croire en
l'être humain
et vous qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire
vous pouvez décider d'agir contre les
pubs sexistes
vous pouvez décider de féminiser tous
les noms de métiers vous pouvez décider
d'offrir à vous à vos filles et vos
petites filles des panoplie de super
héros vous pouvez permettre à vos
garçons de montrer de la tendresse bref
vous pouvez faire en sorte
quotidiennement tous les jours que
l'égalité en tout cas chez vous et
autour de vous soit une réalité
parce que au fond réellement un petit
groupe ou un moyen groupe ou un gros
groupe de citoyennes et de citoyens
engagés de tout leur coeur sur un sujet
qui leur tient à coeur
y a que comme ça que ça réussit alors ce
soir je vous invite à agir a avancé à
inventer et à faire que l'égalité
devienne une réalité
[Applaudissements]